hello everybody and welcome to the
geographical plotting within python
tutorial or basically how to plot data
onto a map using latitude and longitude
to do this we're going to be using a
module called base map which works
alongside mat plot lives so a lot of
your matplotlib skills will be directly
transferable here I'm going to assume
that anybody watching this already has
matplotlib and pil if you don't you
should definitely get mat plot live and
probably go back a little bit and watch
some of the matplotlib tutorials since
they're going to cover some stuff that
i'm going to kind of glaze over here
because I assume you guys already know
so what I plan to cover in this video in
the subsequent few videos is the basics
of displaying a geographical plane how
to customize it and how to begin
plotting on it
pretty much all we're going to do is
simply plot some dots maybe in the
future if I get around to it we can do
some stuff like heat maps but you need
special files to do that and then once
you have the special file it's really
not too difficult so it's actually
harder to plot your own data so anyway
let's go ahead and get started and let's
get what we need in that space map so
what you want to do is head over to your
favorite internet browser and you're
going to want to go to matplotlib org
slash base mat and once you're there
click on the download button and then
it'll be like go here so you'll click
here and you'll end up on SourceForge
and you'll want to pick the latest
version of base map and then you can
pick whatever you've got here there's
the 64-bit 32-bit and there's also just
like the source down here so pick
whichever one you are using if you've
got a 64-bit Python you need to download
64-bit if you've got 32-bit Python you
need to download a 32-bit and once
you've got that all installed we can
begin to work with base map so what you
should always do once you think you've
installed it you should bring over an
interpreter real quick and do import or
I'm sorry from MPL under
or toolkit stop bass Matt import capital
B ASE and maybe and as long as you don't
throw any airs you've done it right so
as long as you haven't let's continue
with you tutorial so as you can probably
guess that's what we're going to import
here as well so we're going to take from
MPL underscore toolkits dot base map
import import base map now what we need
to do is import matplotlib pipe lot as
PLT you guys should be pretty pretty
familiar with this not plot lib dot pi
plot as PLT not period now what we want
to do is we want to set up our base map
logic so what you can kind of think of
this as is when you were building a
figure in matplotlib and you were
setting up maybe a subplot that's kind
of what we're doing here is setting up
our subplot so here's what we're going
to do we're gonna say m4 really really
short equals capital b ASM AP and the
projection is going to be equal we're
going to use mil now what mil is
standing for is a miller cylindrical
projection if you don't care sorry
it's time to learn some stuff basically
the displaying of a map is there's I see
there's about I don't know 20 or 30
different projections that you can use
within base map it just depends on what
you're looking for let me drag it over
these this is the list here and then
I'll pull it up so you can see the whole
thing so from there all the way down
here and so basically I can open up a
few of them so you can kind of get an
idea what I'm talking about when I say
that each one has its own kind of stuff
right so here is our Miller this is what
our map will look like right so it's
squarish but as you can see it gets kind
of distorted especially up here this is
kind of a distorted area we come over
this is an azimuthal equidistant
projection so
there's that you've got this I don't
even notices mnemonic full-disk anyway
you get the idea so depend on like what
exactly you want your your chart to look
like basically you can choose between
all these but for the purposes of this
tutorial just to keep it as basic as
possible we're going to use this Miller
one which I believe is this one so
anyway I just kind of be aware of the
fact that there's just a ton of other
projections but each one has different
stuff like it depends on like if you're
if you're making a flight map let's say
you kind of want your distance between
the two between point A and point B to
be at least visually quite you know
pretty close and then but at the same
time if you're just interested in the
countries then you want the countries to
be fairly proportionate to their actual
size and you don't care so much about
the oceans maybe just depends so there's
just there's like a you know a
projection for every size so that's that
the next thing that we want to do is
specify the corners that we want our
projection so this is you know the full
earth right but if we just wanted maybe
the United States we would specify you
know the coordinates here here here and
here like a box but for now we're going
to just do the full a full size here
just to keep things as simple as
possible so the way this is is LLC our
and our L 80 so this is lower left so ll
lower left CRN our co CRN our corner
latitude equals negative 90 then upper
right corner lat equals 90 backslash
enter then ll corner lawn equals
negative 180 and then upper right corner
lawn equal 20 so we've got a full map
here next thing I need is resolution
equals C and that's we'll talk about
that probably in the next next video so
don't spend too much time explaining
everything here but basically that's how
you know the level of granularity
basically you're going to have but we'll
get to that like I sense then next thing
you want to do is um draw coastlines
empty parameters that's just obviously
going to draw lines off the coast then
we want to fill the continent so MDOT
fill continents continents it's
basically you're originally just because
you did this you would just have like a
blank plot and you got to draw some
coast lines now you're filling the
continents and then MDOT draw a map
boundary and then we'll add a title same
way you've always added titles so quick
base map example and then PLT does show
if we haven't thrown any airs or made in
years this should work
sure enough here is our basic projection
just a quick example of how we can put
something up real quick so anyway that's
your first chart definitely just wanted
to put out a chart get you guys going in
the first video but the next stuff we're
going to continue on in the next video
so if that sounds interesting to you
guys and you should continue on as
always thanks for watching